thi sen on l'appelait déjà la merveille
de l'occident le mont-saint-michel fera
désormais partie du patrimoine mondial
culturel et naturel de l'unesco
la cérémonie se déroulait aujourd'hui
sous un ciel d'azur est tout juste un an
après la décision d'entreprendre les
travaux de désensablement de l'un des
plus beaux modèles l'un des plus beaux
monuments est l'un des plus beaux sites
naturels français isabelle bechler
l'abbaye du mont saint michel était
fermé aux touristes matin pour cause de
visite ministérielle image
traditionnelle d'inauguration monsieur
lebon le directeur général de l'unesco a
concrétisé l'inscription du site au
patrimoine culturel et naturel mondial
car la baie du mont saint michel a
tendance à une tendance inexorable
assemblée depuis un an
la première tranche des travaux de
désensablement a commencé un travail
gigantesque estimé à 100 millions de
francs
aujourd'hui et je crois que l'on ne paye
jamais assez cher pour conserver des
éléments aussi merveilleux du patrimoine
mondial c'est de ralentir le phénomène
d'ensablement du mont saint michel le
mont saint michel ne serait pas ce qu'il
est sans les marais sans la mer de façon
à ce que d'ici 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans on
puisse trouver des méthodes guidée en
sable définitivement lyon sunshine le
village et le monument lui même sont un
chantier permanent restauration travaux
destinés à augmenter la sécurité du
million de visiteurs annuels à améliorer
leur accueil en période d'affluence on a
institué la journée continue pour les
visites et même une garderie pour les
enfants
sur le plan culturel du neuf aussi pour
exploiter au mieux les qualités
pédagogiques du monument
le mont-saint-michel devient le centre
de plusieurs grandes expériences pour le
patrimoine
d'abord nous y organisons dès l'année
prochaine ce que nous appelons des
classes du patrimoine le même qu'il ya
des classes de neige des enfants
viendront ici en hiver passé plusieurs
semaines découvrir jouer avec le
monument sous la conduite de
spécialistes un exemple à suivre
peut-être pour les touristes adultes car
le mont saint michel a au moins autant
de charme l'hiver qu'en plein été il